favorite like moment of like the last  year was in sports that detroit piston  indiana pacer bench clearing brawl  wasn't that great  that was one of the greatest things i've  ever seen i was so confused when i  watched espn that day they were like  that was absolutely disgraceful  basketball fans yeah it just must be  i'm sitting there looking like i'm a  basketball fan i loved it  i thoroughly enjoyed watching out of  shape civilians get the [ __ ] kicked out  of them by professional athletes  it was fascinating  and i think as sports fans we kind of  had it coming right  you get in the game you're all drunk you  like you suck buddy you're a piece of  [ __ ]  and they're always calling them up come  on up here  oh come on up here  well they came up there  they didn't they kicked the [ __ ] out of  everybody it was great  it was like a cartoon  you're like beating up whole rows of  people at once like  i loved every second